okay Vanessa Hudgens celebrates Thirsty
Thursday with a little side boob and
some new Hank it's raw it's it's
vulnerable it's sexy
that it is check out the 31 year old
actress hanging out with a girlfriend at
a tattoo parlor in NYC she shared the
sultry snap on Instagram showing off her
new tat a dainty sunflower in a very
sexy spot she joked in the caption that
the pic was to conclude our Thirsty
Thursday I'm stoked
Vanessa's floral tat was created by
tattoo artist dragon in New York City
and that fresh ink comes after a fresh
split last week according to what
multiple reports the actress and her
longtime boyfriend actor Austin Butler
have gone their separate ways
after nearly a decade together each
couple has their own journey yes they do
and Vanessa has wasted no time proving
she's living her best life just one day
after the news broke that the couple had
called it quits she hit the red carpet
for the premiere of her latest action
flick bad boys for life yes girl he
wanted to do action now you're in the
next bad boys smiling and blowing kisses
to the crowd
Vanessa wowed in a dramatic asymmetrical
white gown which featured a gauzy
flowing at thigh-high skirt a feathered
sleeve and crystal bodice
it seems Vanessa is doing just fine
after parting ways with the Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood star although neither
has publicly addressed the split
[Music]